[Music]
computer science is a discipline that is
undergoing a great deal of change and
this requires that as computer science
educators that we come up with new ways
to teach the new generation of students
[Music]
Alice is a system to try to get people's
first exposure to learning how to
program a computer to be a pleasant one
we have got a system where students can
make small 3d animated movies and/or 3d
video games and they do that by dragging
words in a system where they cannot make
a mistake
I came to CMU right at the point where
we were starting work on Alice 2 and one
of the major goals for that was sort of
the drag-and-drop interface and to kind
of get the technical hurdles that people
have with programming out of the way so
between that in the fact that you can
see what's going on and you actually
want to do it in the first place then we
we found that Alice was really
intriguing to a lot of people we saw
that the majority of children majority
of adults are visual learners and Alice
teaches visually and so you get a chance
to watch what your program actually does
in a way that no other tool does we
really believe that alice is one of the
few silver bullets we've seen that might
be able to turn around the massive
decline in CS majors nationwide
[Music]
I'm excited about what's going to happen
with 3.0 I've been fortunate enough to
work with the Alice team there's some
intermediate steps that we have taken so
that my students in my course right now
are actually working with the Alice
models in Java code this is a way in
which they are forced to confront
semicolons and braces and the technical
details of a more production oriented
language and yet they can still do
things that's engaging that still feels
real to them randy pausch did a
sabbatical at EA's main campus here in
Redwood City and one of the things that
came out of our many conversations
together was the idea of how EA Sims
assets could be used in the Alice
teaching tool it's you know it's such an
intelligent smart way to promote the
study of computer science what we're
trying to do with programming is allow
people to figure out how to get machines
that they have do the work that they
need them to do and allow people to do
the things that they're best at which is
creatively solving problems we take on
the real problems here and we take great
pride in doing real things and things
that matter and of course the great
thing about Carnegie Mellon is we come
to work every day and say that let's not
do it the way we've always done it let's
not do it the way everybody else always
does
[Music]
you